il a ses propres affiches et son propre
slogan il a même sa propre publicité à
la radio nous écouter
maxime bernier mène une campagne unique
au québec peut-être même au pays sa
voiture comme le reste dit tout c'est
lui la vedette bien plus que son chef
où sont partis les gens connaissent donc
on dit c'est un gars qui nous rassemble
c'est un gars qui me connaît c'est basé
sur les fesses est basé sur l'expérience
que j'ai avec les beaucerons dans son
local électoral
la machine semble bien rodé une centaine
de bénévoles met l'épaule à la roue pour
le faire élire une quatrième fois
parmi eux son père gilles bernier ex
député conservateur fut indépendant et
ancien ambassadeur du canada en haïti
il est fier de la campagne que mène son
fils est selon lui la crise des migrants
en europe donnent du fil à retordre au
chef conservateur actuellement au mans
grosse parlera peut-être qu'il ya des
correctifs à apporter mais j'imagine que
dans l'entourage de monsieur harper il
ya des gens qui sont capables de le
conseiller
c'est également cette attitude qui
dérange cette femme croisée par hasard à
saint georges en beauce
c'est elle qui d'entrée de jeu nous a
parlé de cette bouleversante photo du
garçon sur la plage nous avons beaucoup
je vais trouver que le premier ministre
a mal réagi bien mal réagi ce ton
kg qui regardent la pop ou cement l'eau
chez nous maxime bernier pourrait perdre
son vote en octobre même si elle a voté
pour lui par le passé des changements à
cause qu'on n'a pas un bon député n'est
peut-être pas le photographe yvon
thibodeau accompagne maxime bernier
pratiquement partout depuis ses premiers
pas en politique il ya des gens notre
nom et d'abb ont voté pour marseille
ça veut pas dire pour le soir ainsi même
dans une circonscription où le
conservateur à la faveur des électeurs
depuis presque 10 ans le vent pourrait
tourner alors il pourrait récolter votre
vote
non je vais essayer du nouveau
changement
maxime bernier lui multiplie les
poignées de main sur le terrain
peut-être qu'en beauce je suis peut-être
plus populaire que mon chef
il n'y a pas de doute la politique cool
bel et bien dans les veines de maxime
bernier qui ne nie pas aspirer aux plus
hautes fonctions
on se pense que l'avenir peut nous
amener la première ambition que j'essaie
de contient des petites bosses mais
j'aime et des balises et d'aider j'aime
la politique et on verra maxime bernier
a gagné toutes les élections haut la
main en 2006 et en 2008 il a même été le
député québécois a récolté est la plus
forte majorité tous partis confondus
mais de répéter cet exploit pourrait
s'avérer plus difficile cette fois ci
si julie dufresne radio-canada
beauceville